le plastique est un vrai problème pour
nous tous on en trouve dans partout sur
la terre on trouve dans les rivières on
en trouve dans les océans ça c'est bien
connu on trouve dans les sols en haut
des montagnes et dans les fosses
océaniques il faut c'est un problème
qu'il faut absolument résoudre pour cela
j'ai déposé en novembre dernier une
résolution à l'assemblée nationale qui
incite la france à agir plus fortement
au niveau international pour résoudre ce
problème de pollution plastique cette
résolution a été votée à l'unanimité des
u9 groupes politiques de l'assemblée
nationale le 29 novembre dernier elles
demandent trois choses d'agir au niveau
européen pour éviter notamment que la
méditerranée ne viennent pas à nouveau
giroud savez ces espaces qu'on appelle
autrement les cantines en plastique elle
demande également au niveau
international que la france enclencher
une dynamique pour fédérer les
recherches et qu'on obtienne
l'équivalent d'un giec du climat mais
cette fois ci sur les plastiques et
enfin toujours au niveau international
la résolution demande à ce que la france
appuie les initiatives portées par le
pérou et le rwanda pour mettre en place
un traité international contre la
pollution plastique alors faire voter la
résolution n'est pas une fin en soi il
faut maintenant s'assurer qu'elle a bien
se concrétiser donc pour cela je vais
vérifier que cette résolution va faire
l'objet de débats lors de la présidence
française de l'union européenne et
également lors de la 5ème session des
nations unies pour l'environnement dont
la france à la coprésidence lutter
contre la pollution plastique est
indispensable c'est un phénomène qui
nous concerne tous tous les milieux sont
concernés notre santé peut être impacté
donc cette lutte contre la pollution
plastique ce phénomène préserver notre
santé et celle de nos enfants préserver
notre biodiversité notre environnement